Facebook shares were up today after CEO
Mark Zuckerberg said the company's
privacy data scandal has had no
meaningful impact on usage or ad sales
CEO Mark Zuckerberg is about to come to
Capitol Hill to explain himself tonight
chief congressional correspondent Mike
Emanuel sets the stage and explores what
congressional regulation of Facebook
might look like ahead of his appearance
in front of key congressional committees
in the House and the Senate next week
Facebook CEO Mark Zuckerberg has already
started his apology tour we didn't focus
enough on preventing abuse and thinking
through how people could use these tools
to do harm as well and that goes for
fake news foreign interference and
elections hate speech in addition to
developers and data privacy we didn't
take a broad enough view of what our
responsibility is and and that was a
huge mistake it was - and the company's
chief operating officer is telegraphing
what Congress might hear we are
fundamentally shifting the way we think
about this we are no longer just trying
to build social experiences we are also
and we always were concerned about
privacy but not enough we are also
taking more proactive steps to get ahead
of the possible misuse Facebook is in
hot water after revelations Cambridge
analytic amiss use the data of 87
million of the social media platforms
users and that third parties have
accessed data on its 2.2 billion active
users without their consent
Minnesota Democrat senator Amy Klobuchar
notes the 87 million figure is roughly
the combined populations of New York
Texas and California and Klobuchar who
have a chance to question Zuckerberg
signaled her approach I intend to ask
what he is doing to protect the privacy
of Americans and how he plans to address
the significant breaches in security and
trust that have occurred over the last
year Republicans Senate Judiciary
Chairman Chuck Grassley says users
deserve to know how their information is
shared and secured Senate Commerce
Chairman Republican John Thune says the
revelations have generated significant
concern about Facebook's role in our
democracy congressional sources say
these hearings will be the first step
toward increased scrutiny of the tech
industry with a particular
focus on the data and online advertising
business model Brett be fascinating to
watch Mike thanks